[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم في مجزيمباء من قناه الجزيره
اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه استشهاده
شابا فلسطيني واصابه اخرين برصاص الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي فجر اليوم في مخيم بلاطه
الشرقيه نابلس بالضفه الغربيه وقال مراسل
الجزيره عن المخيمه شهد اشتباكات عنيفه
بين الشبان وقوات الاحتلال التي اقتحمت
المخيمه من عده محاور خلال عمليه عسكريه
لاعتقار مطلوبين
صبا جندي اسرائيلي بجروح اثراء عمليه دهس
استهدفت مجموعه من الجنود في بلده حواره
جنوبيه نابلس وافادت مراسله الجزيره بان
جيش الاحتلال اغلق شارع بلده حواره
الرئيسي واغلق المحل التجاريه ونصب عده
حواجز في محيط المنطقه للبحث عن منفذ
عمليه دهس
علامات الخارجيه الامريكيه عن قلقها من
الزياره الاستفزازيه التي قام بها وزير
الامن القومي الاسرائيلي تمارين كثير امس
الاحد الى الحرم القدسيه الشريف وما
صاحبها من خطاب تحريضي وكان بنكفير قد
اقتحم المزيد الاقصى مع عشرات المستوطنين
وقال اثناء اقتحامه الاقصى ان جبل الهيكل
في اشاره الى الحرم القدسي الشريف سيبقى
تحت السياده الاسرائيليه الى الابد حسب
تعبيره في الاثناء عقدت الحكومه
الاسرائيليه جلستها الاسبوعيه داخل نفق
اسفل المسجد الاقصى في خطوه لافته وقال
الرئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو ان
اسرائيل وحدت مدينه القدس بعد الحرب قبل
56 عاما لكن المعركه التي يخوضها لتوحيد
القدس والتصدي للضغوط الغربيه مستمره
قال مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي جيك
سوري ان بلاده لن تمكنه اوكرانيا من
استخدام مساعدات الغرب العسكريه لضرب
روسيا داخل حدودها اضاف صلب انه واشنطن لن
تفرض اي قيود على قدره اوكرانيا على ضرب
الجيش الروسي داخل الاراضي الاوكرانيه بما
في ذلك القرن كما قال ان واشنطن لن تزود
كييف بمقاتلات 16 من مخزونها القومي بل
سيكون ذلك عبر طرف ثالث
في المقابل قال وزير الخارجيه الروسيه ان
الغرب حدد مهمته بالقضاء على روسيا كمنفس
جيوسي وليس فقط هزيمتها في اوكرانيا وذلك
عبر قرارات قمه مجموعه السبعه التي انعقدت
هيروشيما
قال بيان السعوديه امريكي في اطلاق النار
في السودان يدخل حيز التنفيذ الساعه
التاسعه وخمسه واربعين دقيقه من الصباح
اليوم الاثنين بتوقيت الخرطوم اضاف البيان
وانا الاتفاق ستدعمه اليه مراقبه مدعومه
دوليا من قبل السعوديه والولايات المتحده
وذلك لاول مره منذ بدء مواجهات
السودان اعلن طرفان نزاع التزامهما
بالهدنه المرتقبه وفقا لاتفاق جدا الجديد
لوقف اطلاق النار اما ميدانيا فقد جدارت
معارك عنيفه بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع في ام درمان وسجلت غارات
العالم واقعه مختلفه بالخرطوم بينما خيم
هدوء حذر في نياله بعد معارك داميه اوقعت
18 قتيله
قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ان على
الجمهوريين ان يعرفوا انه لن يتم ايجاز اي
صفقه بين الحزبين وفقا لشروطهم خلال
مفاوضات رفع سقف الدين العام وكان بايدن
كشف انه يدرس احتمال اللجوء الى اليه
دستوريه تمنحه صلاحيات لتجاوز الكونغرس
لتجنيب البلاد التخلف عن صدادات الديون
هذا وقال من الامريكيه ان بايدن اتفق مع
رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي كيفن مكار في
على اجتماعي مفوضيه الطرفين بشان ازمه
الدين العام كما ان باينس سيلتقي مكارثه
في وقت لاحقا الاثنين في البيت الابيض هذا
يتمسك مكان في مطالب خفض الانفاق قبل اي
اتفاق مع الديمقراطيين بشان ازمه الدين
العام
انتهى الموجز مرشدنا في امان